interestingly there are increasing
attempts to stop certain books from
being published that overwhelmingly
seems to be coming from the left so when
there are books that are deemed to be
politically incorrect or not
sufficiently woke or they transgress
some line you will see online campaigns
to get Publishers to drop certain things
off of it there was a book that came out
a couple years ago called American dirt
and it was a book written by a white
American about a Hispanic woman
illegally migrating to the United States
and that became a huge flash point the
book was published it was a massive
publishing success so it didn't work but
in the broader context of cancel culture
there are more and more visible attempts
to shut down certain types of speech